hello everyone I hope you're all having
a great Sunday and just a little
something before I start the game I've
been contacted by the winners of the
five Amazon gift cards and a one user
though una poca cosas your YouTube or
Google+ settings are probably probably
set to super private so I'm unable to
answer you what I need for you to do is
if you're watching this video just send
me your email address so I can send the
gift card and I still wasn't contacted
by the winner of the main prize
lukovitch the championship chess set but
okay it is the weekend I understand I
will give it one more day and then I
will try to contact you and one other
thing hmm it seems my videos were being
translated into other languages for the
past three months by by subscribers and
the YouTube hasn't notified me of this
so I just checked they were there are
like 50 videos translated into other
languages you know to Russia and Italian
Portuguese a lot of languages and thank
you very much you know it really means a
lot to me that my videos are available
to people who don't speak English
unfortunately YouTube doesn't tell me
which user did this it's you know it's
just under community contributions so if
any of you have translated any of my
videos just write in any video mine
hashtag translation or hashtag translate
so I can properly thank you okay that
being said this game was played 10 years
ago in 2007 in the European Cup it was
played between Joe Bob adore and Arkady
night is a very strong grandmaster from
Azerbaijan and I was checking out a lot
of games a lot of your suggestions for
my today's game but as today is Jo
Bhalla 34th birthday I decided to show
Joe Baba game and the opening used in
this game is the Berlin defence and I
know what you're gonna say oh no man not
if not the Berlin defense but that's
what I like about Jabbar he can make a
game in the boolean defense seem very
interesting so let's see the game Joe
Bala has the white pieces and he plays
efore we have e5 Knight to f3 knight c6
and Bishop to b5 the rule opus and now
we have Knight to f6 the Berlin defense
this is this is the move kramnik used to
rob because part of his world
championship title
we have castles by Joe baba and Knight
captures on e4 d4 and Knight to d6 black
can go for a line eg after sandy for
just as well but after rook e1 and
something like d5 Queen character son d4
it's considered a bit better for white
and well you generally don't want to
play against dibala
with Queens on the board so after d4
Knight to d6 was played Bishop captures
on c6 d captures and c6 and D captures
on e5 Knight to f5 we have Queen
captures King captures and we reach the
famous Berlin ending Knight to c3 and we
have h6 controlling that g5 square white
could have gone for Knight to g5
immediately for example but he hasn't
developed any of his pieces there really
is no need to do this but I can simply
play King gate and everything is fine so
first Knight c3 and now h6 no
controlling the g5 square h3 and this is
a very very useful move it's not just
copying blacks h6 move white does have
an advantage on the King side he has
four points two blacks three points so
white will at some point want to push g4
and therefore and you know really get
his pawn majority rolling Bishop to d7
we have b3 Knight to e7 preparing 96 to
create an attack against the e5 pawn and
in this position usually in those days
Bishop d2 was the main move but here we
have a novelty by Joe baba he plays
Bishop to a3 and here we have B 6v6
probably with an idea of c5 and locking
that Bishop on a3 black should have gone
for something like Knight to g6
immediately and after Bishop captures on
f8 and rook captures this position would
be okay for black to play but as a
bishop to a3 was a novelty black didn't
find it the best response over the board
so a b6 and here we have rook a to d1
pinning that bishop so Arkady
immediately place came to see it
we have Bishop characters on e7 Bishop
captures
97 and night to d4 we have rook to b8
and now f4 and okay
white managed to do what white wants to
do when playing white in the Brillion
defense he started his pawn majority and
the King side is preparing g4 and we
have g6 now f5 by Joe baba and Bishop to
b4 now attacking that night and C 3 that
is undefended black could have tried
something like G characters on f5 but
after Knight captures on f5 attacking
the bishop on e7 and Bishop to f8 after
G for this is this is a great position
for white he has this beautiful night
and f5 if what captures it in any moment
only this light square bishop can
capture it then G captures an f5 white
will have a beautiful point there so
after f5 Arkady tried Bishop to b4 and
now I don't know if Joe baba had this
position planned all over B when you
play in a style that jamala plays in you
kind of have to have a lot of things
prepared at home so he might have this
prepared you know prior to the game here
Joe Baba doesn't react to this night
being attacked he plays F captures on g6
and what do you do here well Arkady
played Bishop characters on c3 he
captured the night but F captures on g6
if you play something like this then e 6
is coming with an attack on the bishop
and after Bishop e8 Knight to e4 and
this position is it's great for white
this this is a this is a very strong
pawn so arkady decided he's gonna try
and play up a piece so Bishop captures
on c3g captures on f7 and our rook to f8
not allowing f8 point Roop to f6 now
preparing the move east 6 at some point
and c5 taking the night away and this is
a very very poisonous position I will
just show what happens if Arkady decided
to play Bishop captures on d4 as he is
up a piece so why not exchange pieces if
Bishop captures on d4 for example rook
captures on d4 and now after c5
to d5 and after King to the eight as
black would really enjoy playing King to
e7 White has this beautiful move rook to
e6 as the bishop is pinned this is this
is very nice
so after something like a a5 Rupe to e8
check rook captures now II 6 and for
example King to e7 rook captures on d7
King captors and e6f captures on e 8th
with Queen with check rook captures and
rook captures on c7 Jabbar would be up
upon and with this beautiful rock on c7
probably winning the game
so after up to f6 we have c5 now Knight
to f3 protecting protecting d5 pawn and
Bishop to b5 and unfortunately yo baba
can't push e 6 yet because this Bishop
is will be attacking the rook on f6 sake
please King to have to improving the
position of a scheme which is something
you always want to do in an endgame
Arkady still has this inactive rook an
a8 King - b7 preparing to bring the rook
into the game we have worked to f5 now
getting the rook out of the bishops away
and is preparing to push east 6 Bishop
the c6 now II 6 and we have Bishop to e4
with an attack on the rook rook to F for
attacking the bishop bishop to g6 and in
this position the grandmaster from
azerbaijan orchid in irish resigned to
the game without even waiting for a
reply from chabela as these two past
bones are simply too powerful black
black doesn't have a move in this
position you can never bring this a rock
into the game if you play something like
white in the single player rook to f1
and his idea is pretty simple he will
move the king he will move the knight
and then push a 7 at some point when the
two rooks will be defending the f7 pawn
so black doesn't really have anything
here he can't bring good work into the
game the e7 wins instantly and it's very
hard you can't even play something like
Bishop captures on f7 to give up give up
a piece you know to grab the points
because e 7
coming and after group moves rook
captures on f7 and you know a completely
winning and game for white so after this
Bishop to g6 move naught is resigned
again and this beautiful beautiful 25
move game by Java but the robe was
created and you know it was a brilliant
defense means Queens got traded off as
they usually are they reached the
brilliant ending and still we have a 25
miniature by Jabba sacrificing a piece
in the end game so very nice and once
again happy birthday to Jabbar Amador
and may he may he you know entertain the
chess world for many years to come so
that's it that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it as usual you can check to my
previous videos here think all for
watching and I will see you soon